no no no no no no no no no no that songs
in your head don't lie whose right
trailer may have dropped on Sunday but
it's a blue monday up in here so we have
the first trailer the teaser trailer the
Wonder Woman 1984 that takes place in
that's right 1984 yes you could just you
can tell by the song no no no no no so
Pedro Pascal who he's had quite a year
quite a few episodes anyway one is he's
the bad guy he looks like the baddie and
he has a rock that grants wishes what I
get from the trailer anyway and it looks
like Wonder Woman brings Steve Trevor
back play the truth I don't I don't
exactly know how he's back I know he's
rocking that fanny pack not everyone can
do that that's important but if I'm
going by what the trailers telling me
apparently think about finally having
everything you always wanted and now
he's back so I imagine it's because of
that Kristen Wiig as cheetah I still
don't know I was a little skeptical at
first and I know Kristen Wiig has acting
chops but when she's cast as cheetah you
can't help but be like so they're going
a little comedic with this one so many
times yeah all the time
at first it kind of comes across as this
Selina Kyle and Batman Returns format at
first he's a little awkward then boom
Jesus head turning bombshell that that
guy clearly wants to leave his wife for
and one brief scene a dialogue with
Diana just isn't enough to gauge it
really I still don't know how they're
doing cheetah
personality-wise for even if cheetah is
gonna be the half human half cheetah
cheetah or is she gonna be human and
dressed up in an outfit and be really
good at acrobatics but I'm glad that
they're bringing back that fun element
of the first Wonder Woman that I really
love and that's Diana was a fish out of
water she was in a new land she didn't
know how things worked and they brought
that back only it's Steve Trevor he's in
a new land he's like Oh what suddenly is
1984 Steve Rogers he adapted pretty
quickly he just punched a bag to death
Steve Trevor's like that's art she's
like now it's a trash can so the roles
are reversed I like that I like that
fish outta water thing and had fun with
it in the first Wonder Woman I have
faith that they can make it work like as
part of the plot I don't want to walk
away like hangover 2 going as kind of
the same thing it's the first movie only
not as good but it's good to see father
and daughter working together that's
what I see here I mean that's that that
is straight-up Zeus helping her right at
the end I thought she I was like is she
and is that Hawkgirl then I was like
wait a minute that's not Hawkgirl that's
I have to enunciate Hawke because
because I'm always like Hawkgirl and it
sounds like I'm saying hot girl which I
also mean but for the sake of this Huck
girl and I thought that's what that was
I was like wait wait no no that that's
still Wonder Woman all right right
Kingdom Come that's where I saw that
armor myself I mean it's been in other
things but I know it from Kingdom Come
first graphic novel I have a read that
[ __ ] sticks with it so look I dig this
Wonder Woman 1984 trailer I like the
vibe I like the song for now gal gadot
returning as Wonder Woman Steve Trevor
rocking that fanny pack and paid you a
Pascale getting his rock on that's
enough for me so sweet teaser trailer
that's what you need for a teaser
trailer right so the teaser trailer for
Wonder Woman 1984 have you seen it what
did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]